the NFL is officially having a yard sale
would you like a snack how about an Eli
Apple what'll it be come on come on it's
trade time in the NFL come on down come
on down - come on Dan - come on down
hi guys hey I saw you were gonna get on
a roll there I was - that's what I kind
of always expect you to do I appreciate
the hard sale song I did not most of the
things I do or off the top of my head
because I don't believe in preparation I
am great way to go rhymes offensive
coaching staff of POD air you what's
wrong with that I dare you Todd Haley is
a prepared individual app you know what
he is
yeah man um all right so what's good how
you livin I'm livin good so the last
time we talked Monday Amari Cooper had
just been traded from trades have
happened since then
Daymond Harrison snacks as you may call
him Eli Apple was also traded trades in
the NFL hold on you got a tattoo and
we're not gonna talk about that oh you
want to leave with that how could we not
it was man enough to get tattooed you
saw this Sims and Lefko show episode
Sims as you may have heard on Mondays
podcast locking it in
Chiefs Patriots in the AFC getting a bye
Rams Saints to the NFC getting a bye
said you could put it in ink putter
today I went and I got that the the
current predictions all my arms he put
it in ink I did I'm letting my sleeves
down right now just because they told me
to let it heal and let it rest right but
you got a tattoo while you're there - a
little more personal I did because I've
been saying for like five years to my
family that I was gonna get their
initials - I mean I have other peoples
tat names tattooed on my body in case
you haven't heard right in case you
haven't shown your buddy again I mean
Kyle Shanahan boasts cave rod Beiber's
Montrell flowers I only talked to two
out of the four anymore so if I only
talked to two out of the four how the
hell can I not have my family on there
plus I have a long horn and of course I
love the Longhorns but what means more
to me than Philip Charlotte oh and my
wife dog so I got their initials I like
that yeah
Thanks yeah but I got my tattoos and
people lost their minds
yeah shout-out to George Kittel who DM
me and said bro are those tats real and
I was like yeah 49ers I think you should
be concerned I do about what the way
people view you yes you're freaking
snoop so Sara Sara Lowen came up to me
in the hallway and she goes I almost
cried last night and her husband was
like they're probably not real and she
goes I don't know a lot of people think
that I'm just out of nowhere gonna go
and get an incomplete playoff prediction
week seven tattoo on my arm I mean they
think we're better friends and we really
are I mean my girlfriend freaked out my
girlfriend said I don't know what you're
capable of with this frickin show yeah I
walked in last night my fiancee said to
me today I don't really get a tattoo for
the show and I said yes Erica
yes he did my mom text me and she goes
I'm not mad you just she didn't yell she
goes I'm not mad you just never told me
you wanted a tattoo yeah everyone really
thought I went for him I'm just pulling
out for week seven of the 2018 NFL
season it was an incomplete playoff
picture on my arms that's it can you
send me that rundown for today yeah of
course please no problem um no but
you're right
people do think that I'm wild and crazy
but I do appreciate that yeah sure I
would rather people view me as that than
me like Bob he's a liar he's only a fake
he's a boring person he's he's really
boring that left go I've emailed it to
you hey snacks whacked it to you as well
oh you're the man you got it all I
appreciate it snacks to the Lions yeah
we just talked about how the Lions could
be a pretty real deal right
Eli Apple to the Saints yeah they needed
a quarter that quarter cornerback this
likely takes them out of the Patrick
Peterson sweepstakes Peterson coming out
and saying I am a cardinal I'm not gonna
be traded did they give him money or
anything like I don't know there might
be like a wink-wink nudge-nudge in the
season the offseason will take care of
your so yeah why what's your take on
that well I'm just so surprised that I
turned so quickly like that I'm actually
surprised that maybe the Cardinals don't
want to make a move and just kind of
have the fire sale like the Raiders and
the Giants and just go it's a new regime
let's start
and have a blank canvas and go from
there and see if we can acquire some
draft picks for a guy like that maybe
they didn't feel like they got the price
they wanted either but I just I'm
shocked that Patrick pulled back so
quickly about it I am a cardinal for
years to come here we know Patrick
Peterson yes really good guy stand up
individual right I also think that we
always underestimate this factor yeah
when you are on social media which I
know you're not and this story comes out
I'm sure he was getting tweeted at eat I
am
DM doll that stuff from hundreds of
people don't leave us don't be a traitor
or Baba and I bet you that kind of works
into your psyche a little bit too but
I'm sure Steve chyme brought him in the
office and said we need you we need you
to be the leader right now you're the
leader of this team yeah but I would
like him to be traded just from like a
football perspective he's wasting away
on a team that's not going anywhere
right
probably for the next 2-3 years yes so
I'd love for him for me Patrick Peterson
and a Chiefs helmet would look beautiful
it looks good in red Patrick Peterson in
a Falcons helmet just fitting that whole
run down even though I don't think the
Falcons are anything that's what I was
just thinking of DeAngelo Hall and pride
time there's a like it would look good
you don't say the Eagles next I I think
you look good anyway we'll say though
that's there would be embody any there
would 100 or said be Eagles fans going
I'm still a little bit gun-shy after
Nnamdi Asomugha
I'm telling you like it's still like
like getting a high-priced corner still
Byron Maxwell like when's the last time
the Eagles got one and it worked
yeah but snacks to the Lions right how
big of a deal is this because this was a
team that wasn't stopping the ball well
in the ground
no they don't stop the run well at all I
mean even last week let up a huge plight
of Kenya on Drake I still think they're
a work in progress as far as just you
know learning how to apply the Bill
Belichick map patrícia defense I still
think there's an issue there with a
Shawn Robinson which I don't totally
understand either yeah he doesn't start
like he didn't start last week - Shawn
hands getting a lot more burning yeah
and then Sylvester Williams really
started in his spot right
but either way knowing Matt Patricia
he's a defensive coach
he still has that old-school mentality
of like we're gonna stop something yes
and I do think he believes in we're not
gonna be bullied in the run game and let
you just smash the ball down our throat
for these long drives one after another
and these big plays that hurt your
football team and obviously the Giants
have had enough and snacks is still
really good I mean really good still for
my money one of the best run Stoppers in
the NFL I mean if not the best you know
on the short list of things you know
I'll pull up the team's just to give a
quick look you know okay you know the
Akeem Hicks and Eddie Goldman are in
that conversation you know Hakeem Hicks
as I look at him a little different
involved Joseph when he is healthy
exactly right who's a little more
athletic than a dame of snacks but that
but what you said before about the
Belichick defense yeah they are always
at their best when they have monsters in
the middle exactly take up to three guys
right and we've been talking about
Detroit being one of those super little
secret sneaky teams yes with a good
offensive line that they have and now
some big dudes on the D line and adding
snacks also takes pressure off of why
the hell isn't Ezekiel Anza coming back
here also when you factor in again all
their linebackers are 240 yeah they're
fast and light right so by putting
snacks in front of them if you're
preventing a guard getting to the next
level
every day that goes on I'm going the
Lions are more and more real yeah I
think so too
III I'm with you a hundred percent I
think with their run game and what
they're doing and the defensive side of
the ball which really as of late like if
I pull up their schedule I know last
week was not beautiful I mean Kenyan
Drake had like week you mentioned the 65
yard run 59 right you know the Green Bay
Packer game okay
the Dallas Cowboy game yeah they got run
on on that one for real so they can't
they can't continue to play that style
football especially when they're gonna
play this style of offensive football
along with it where oh we're gonna we're
now gonna control the ball yes and try
to run the ball and make big plays off a
play-action and Matthew Stafford
occasionally you can't be getting beat
down into the ground with a running game
on your d the other thing is this yeah I
love when guys get traded because I
think it puts a real fire under their
ass when you get rated and you hear that
a
doesn't want you and you go from a team
that's 1 in 6 to a team that's 3 and 3
and in a division dogfight and every
game is gonna be a big deal
what's the weakness of the Vikings
interior offensive line perfect
put snacks there oh you got the Packers
well guess what if Damon Harrison's in
the middle it's harder for Rogers to
scramble up the middle on a third down
yeah I think it's a great move
Eli Apple to the Saints all I've heard
about Eli Apple for the last three years
is he's not that good right I mean he
was never worth the top 10 pick but his
first year he was good you know the
boattrip year that was his rookie year
right I mean he played solid football
that year now last year was a disaster
compounded by him being immature in the
locker room too so I think it just all
led to bad things there's a good thing
the fact that he went to Ohio State and
Lattimore went to Ohio State I do you
know I got like those things too well
I'll go back to what you just said like
change of scenery is good first of all
these are young people like where we
think we're young yeah right
these are like we're talking about a lie
a blues what 23 years old yeah I know he
made some mistakes
that's why can we talk about Amari
Cooper right Cooper's like that's a just
Calvin Riggs where like I'm sold on
Amari so change of scenery change of
energy from your coach change of themes
the coaches are telling you might
resonate better with you on this
coaching staff and you know the other
coaching staff was saying it this way
but this coach says it this way and I
don't know why it just seems to click
better in my brain you know life works
like that some ways so yeah I think
change of scenery will be good for him
and it's a good move for the Saints
that's the most important thing because
we're gonna talk about Ravens Saints
here in a little bit but when there's
one on one or any quarterback can pick a
side with who they want to attack or if
the Saints blitz because they don't have
a great pass rush everyone just goes
where's number 20 where's Ken crawling
crawling I'm gonna throw at him first
down and that's really all that's having
PJ Williams that's a nice little job in
the slot so they needed this to go to
the next level too also because I don't
think their pass rush is going to change
into anything special any time soon No
so Davenport and cam Jordan you're
looking at their
they're good but they're not like I
don't think the Saints are gonna be able
to sit there and pressure with their
front for it against the quality
football team you know they've they
might have some games where they run
over some people only oh look at that a
little bit of pressure I'm Jameis
Winston we're we're at the point of the
year now over the Saints we're going no
you're being measured dinners the
Vikings the Rams if you play the
Patriots in the Super Bowl what are you
going to be able to do my only hope for
that pass rush though is since Marcus
Davenport was raw when he was drafted
yes he could be one of those guys that
in week 14 were going I don't even
recognize him from week four he changed
so much he's good and he's very close
right now
I mean he's he he pushed big Ronnie
Stanley around a few times during that
game bus
I feel like Ronnie Stanley does get
pushed around some day yeah I mean he
can Bryce I mean that old line though in
there Baltimore there they're the real
deal but you have the Saints their 27th
and football and sacks 13 sacks on the
whole year and they really that is an
issue for them is being able to just get
after the quarterback with the front
four and I don't think you can always
depend on that and you want to keep
people in coverage so now they got
another guy the Saints are one of those
teams though that I'm okay if they blitz
because I'm okay if the offense gets the
ball back quick yeah I get that I
understand that the other side of the
Eli Apple Damon Harrison trades right
are the Giants right we are selecting se
Quan Barclay because we can make a run
this season yes one-in-six sell
everything yeah so that's how much
forward thinking they did they did seven
weeks of forward thinking yes that's it
that was the well I mean how am I not
looking at all of this as an abject
failure well it is a failure but it was
a failure that they of course did not
think it was going to really happen this
way how can you and me yeah watch Eli
for these last few years yeah and have a
more accurate observation than a GM and
a front office that spent probably weeks
looking through all of the game film
interviewing people studying everything
giving analysis how are we more accurate
than them well I don't know if we are
more you
to them I think you're missing the most
important person in that conversation
there and that would be the owners and I
think that Eli Manning is in the
Department of the owner says what's
going to happen with Eli Manning and I
think he decided we're gonna give him
one more year cuz of he's given us two
Super Bowl championships in a great
career and they were gonna give it one
more go with him do you think part of
the reason Pat Shermer was hired was
because he took a scene as backup Case
Keenum for his entire career and gave
him one a top 10 NFL season and they
went maybe if we bring this guy again he
can do that to Eli I think that being
able to answer all the tough questions
along with it having a no-nonsense way
about him yes I think all of those
things kind of led them to being hired
but there's one thing that you have not
heard about from Pat Shermer this whole
time he's been here it's never wavered
from Eli's our guy
Eli's our guy he's our guy we're not
trading him either guess who else has
there well no I know there's nobody else
but he also knows that part of the he
got the job and they told them no Eli
Manning's our quarterback this year
don't even try to and he knows that and
he's being the the good citizen they're
two owners I just can't I hate that you
hate that I just hate that I but I've
brought this up to you before of these
are supposed to be the smartest most
well-thought-out football people in the
entire world and they're supposed to
make decisions to win Super Bowls yeah
and I feel like we do this every three
months where we sit here and it's
another conversation about a team that's
not trying to win the Super Bowl they're
playing because of politics because of
some yeah personal relationship yeah oh
yeah or or politics yeah it kills me at
this job yes with your fans that's
really what it is after the backlash
what they took last year and I'm sure
there was some conversations to the I'm
Manning behind closed doors and
everything else but yeah that's what it
was it was a politic move and dust don't
forget it was just three weeks ago where
giant fans were still going no idealize
not the problem it was the Houston
Texans win right they were like he was
22 or 25 right and then the Saints game
you know they made up excuses for him in
that game remember that was the game I
said drew Brees was under more pressure
than Eli Manning and we all we talked
about was Eli Manning being
pressure the whole game so it took you
know we just got to remember where we
were and yes owners play to the fanbase
to a degree they do and Eli is loved in
the New York area which he should be he
gave them two Super Bowl championships
and they were special because like they
were waiting the Patriots they were over
the Patriots and we didn't expect them
they were nine and seven and we're like
oh we're good we got him to play us well
we wanted one
woah we won another one we win this one
we're going to Super Bowl we can't do
that whoa we get to the Super Bowl he's
like yeah he's like a crappy boyfriend
that surprised you with roses toys I
always will standby he's like the worst
great quarterback ever that's my fun
people ask me like my friends back what
do you think about he's like the worst
great quarterback ever and they're like
oh and then would that make Jeff George
the best worst quarterback ever don't
die all I know is Jeff George and Warren
Moon
Phineas ball prettiest balls ever I mean
Dirty Diana said it that's when you know
it jumped out oh my gosh Christopher
that Jeff George could really throw the
football yeah mom but he's thrown it to
the Giants four times in this first half
the thing about Eli is I feel like the
Giants season is officially over they've
officially you're not yeah yeah they
officially though have reached the point
of the year where they're gonna win some
games here they're gonna be some games
there they're gonna get a lot of $10
bets in Sims and Lefko they're gonna be
the team that their whole job now is to
kind of mess it up for other tasks right
and I think that that Monday night game
playing the 31st ranked defense the NFL
and up until a few minutes left in that
game having like 10 point or six points
yeah six six points right is really all
you needed to know no and it was the
offense and and I'm watching Odell on
the sidelines and schirmer's like I know
I know like he kept saying he was like I
know and Odell was sitting on the bench
and he's touching his hair and he's very
aware of what he's doing he definitely
was and I'm sitting there and I'm going
mobile I'll Paul's career pup
potentially in doubt it's our possible
career-ending neck surgery and I love
blop oh yeah
covered with lead stinks it does but I
am watching the game and then there's
the clip of of Shermer going throw it to
Odelle when like Odelle was clearly open
the corner was like it looked like about
to fall down on that little jet sweet
pass over there he had it you gotta just
pull the trigger I don't know what else
to say
and then also can we talk about the Eli
nonsense with his hands after Eli throws
a ball he he has figured out a way I
watched his shoulder I don't know what
he does he puts all of the blame on his
receivers because he knows in his head
he goes 1 2 3 motion because he goes now
the cameras gonna go on me and he's
always going and he like he like arcs
his hand out like like and and everyone
knows he's like oh the receiver didn't
finish the route like that's a universal
sign for finish the round yeah and then
it causes Witten and boog to be like I
don't think odo came out of that break
the right way but yeah I don't agree
with I mean didn't that I think that
Odell was correct at that moment but yes
again
those are possible and act politics of
the position and also when you we talked
about Blake bortles right when I always
know Blake bortles isn't throwing the
ball well he's hopping around and like
oh gosh I hope it hits the target I know
when I after I got hurt and I was not me
like in training camp and I was like
missing throws I was the same way I was
always like oh just move over there like
I was always trying to find something to
justify why my throw was off like now
years later you look back look I was I
was them I knew I knew not yours yeah I
knew I knew a few weeks after that I was
like I'm the [ __ ] one that's off here
yeah but yes in the heat of the moment
and you want to make it work you kind of
start to oh just do this do this but
those are signs of going you're not good
anymore or you're not yourself anymore
you're bowling analogy on Monday was
perfect because if everyone has had that
experience of bowling right you throw
the ball down the lane and you're aiming
at the middle pin right and then it goes
to the far right and you're like why did
it go to the middle way right you're
leaning
right and we blame the ball everybody in
the Box you get idiot yeah yeah
turn on ESP just called Eli Manning an
idiot I did yeah turn on ESPN Sunday at
1 o'clock watch the PBA you don't see it
really yeah it's when footballs on new
sweater for you know I've had this one
yes where is wwbd but yeah it's it's sad
for the Giants what were you gonna say I
think this whole quarterback mannerisms
thing is interesting yeah I'm interested
I always watch that I have gotten d DM s
before about this and I think we've
talked about this before about little
ticks and stuff yeah people do like
which drew Brees licks his fingers all
the time both hands after every throw he
could throw a ball in the flat the plays
not over and he's already gone and he
pulls down his shoulder yes every time
what does the yeah it's like his
shoulders constantly dislocated like oh
gosh like he's uncomfortable in his own
skin you know I know Flacco goes Payton
always used to pull up his right thigh
protector you know he used to pull it up
and then walk down like the same thing
every time
everybody has their little did you do
any weird [ __ ] I really I'm sure I don't
think I had anything like crazy you
probably me was more subtle like
probably doing this of my hand like
trying to get moisture in there we're in
a towel with just a little bit of water
on it to grab it just so my hands were
moist when I grab the football Omar from
house of highlight said one of his
favorite things to do when he's watching
football is watch guys hold on to their
chest yeah that's right
like put their hands in their neck and
just and he's like why do they do that
is it just comfort comfort it truly is
cuz you're sitting there on the sideline
for so long right
I mean you can get sore standing on the
sideline like I used to be like in the
third quarter when you're like you know
holding the clipboard like holy [ __ ] my
back's tight just from standing yeah
could you just stand and that's why you
stand like I start getting a tripod
going yeah I started doing it at all
but yeah you start to do that and then
you just start to go damn I mean I've
been standing over here for like three
hours now so when you put them right
here you can kind of lock your fingers
in there
holy [ __ ] you're just like hanging it is
funny though just like I never thought
about him looking all these NFL players
hold
their chest yeah any other good ones
from history of quarterback so you can
think of your dad do anything weird or
out way or Marino or Favre now this
could be a hashtag we could you be QB
tix those are the ones that jump ball
sometimes I need to see them
these were they just rape my memory and
then I go that's right that's what he
always did but those three for sure real
I mean yes I got them down without a
doubt they are very repetitive people
there was one quarterback that we forgot
in terms of Jaguar possibility yeah
right Sam Bradford yeah Arizona yeah I
know you're at home going he's gonna get
hurt in the first game that is the story
of the man of made of glass but Sam
Bradford I mean he did have the second
highest completion percentage in a
season before and I'm not saying that
that's what you look for in a
quarterback but I am saying for a team
like the Jaguars a guy that can hit
slants might be pretty useful yeah I
mean hey listen Sam Bradford still a
quality thrower the football he's a
little bit of a you know wooden Indian
back there for lack of a better phrase
he's not gonna move around or make plays
on the run or do anything like that but
yes if he's given time he's gonna put
the ball on the money and he certainly
would be an up greatest in the drop back
pass game overall then and I'm mad we
didn't think about him right right off
the bat because there are another do
they have Mike Lennon as their third
right so and we know Josh Rosen's the
future just like we've talked about with
Cleveland Browns and Tyrod Taylor that
that would make sense but at the same
time I think we're in too deep like I
said and they've made their bed and
they're gonna cozy on up to it now all
right solution percentage is just way
too overrated I know you think it just
drives me crazy I mean too much of the
quarterback rating is based on
completion percentage I mean Eli Manning
has this highest quarterback rating in
his whole career right now do you know
that his whole career never had better
completion percentage yeah he's got a
94.1 come I really don't want to harp on
the Monday Night Football crew but when
they spent the first quarter talking
about how Eli's check downs were a part
of the offense and not a sign of
weakness and we're defending him the
entire time and putting all the blame on
Nate's older
this monday night football crew they
took shots at him early but they got out
of they got it out of the way they said
if you remember they were like we should
we wish he'd stop watching the rush so
much and he just needs to hang in there
a little bit more and they made those
comments and then they never really went
back to that would be yes but worst crew
ever well I like booger he's alright
Oh booger peeing his pants bugger peeing
as that was hilarious
what's the NFL gonna do about the booger
cart right the booger cream the Burger
cranes like that that would that would
piss me off
oh yeah I saw our guy license plate guy
Giants fan like I'm trying to watch the
game and boogers right in front and
their answer is no there's a TV on the
back yeah which is apparently on like a
30-second delay no okay so there you are
you've paid $400 to get it bro four of
the game the ball comes down to your
side of the field you go look at this
honey this is why I bought this we're
gonna see Aaron Rodgers right next to
Khalil Mass gonna dive right over the
goal line I can't see there's this big
machine right I mean that's just to me
like the NFL hypocrisy once again I have
not seen one of your crazy used one time
I have not heard one time where it goes
booger from your perspective what are
you gaining well I'm noticing a lot of
pulling guards I haven't even heard that
it's just chiming in normal announcing
the game was announcing the game I know
and admitting that he peed his pants a
lot on the bench yeah and your first
reaction was did he pee his pants or did
he pee in a little side yeah right we've
all peed in the garbage can I mean
that's sometimes you got to do that who
has to take the garbage can full of piss
out oh I mean I don't know the guy the
ground crews after they don't know they
just think it's yellow Gatorade that's
so gross I know so you're saying that a
lot of NFL players go over the sidelines
they pee into a garbage can yeah like
other coaches hold up towel you'll see
three of the equipment guys are the the
trainer's just hold up towels and go
like all right piss in here real quick
why not do what Odell didn't run the
locker room and pee in a bathroom yeah
you could if you have enough time or you
feel like okay I can get this done in a
hurry but sometimes guys are like okay
we might stop him do a three and out and
I really like to get this out of my
system so I don't have to sit over here
and think of
being that have you ever peed in your
pants as a football player no never
okay yeah you know me come on I couldn't
I couldn't live with myself
yeah the sanitary issues would be such
an issue for me I'd be like oh I would
be grossed out by myself plus I'd be
like damn are my shoes squeaking now too
cuz I got some urine uh there you would
really throw you off it really even
throw me off what happens if you were
peeing in a trash can a little bit cut
on your Jersey like you would totally be
the guy going out to be like I'm like
trying to wipe it I'm gonna dump some
water on there a little talked about all
your issues with Center butt crack sweat
though so surprised that I know
well [ __ ] when you're getting paid the
way you're getting paid and you want to
be good at that you just go okay old
swamp ass here we go I'll put that crack
our finger in the crack no problem I
have a few other big-name guys that are
being mentioned a lot for possibly being
traded okay I don't want to know where
they can be traded to right I want to
know do you think the team would be
willing to part ways not yet we already
talked about Cardinals being a little
protective of Patrick Peterson a lot of
rumors about Demaryius Thomas and the
Broncos yeah and with how well Courtland
Sutton has looked so far I do get it
especially with Demaryius getting about
a seventeen point five million dollar
cap charge for next year Wow it's a big
number that is a huge number a guy that
might be the three on his team right now
well that that might be the reason why
he doesn't get traded more than us he
also said on Monday there's a chance
quote my time is coming up here yeah I
saw rumors yesterday that Emmanuel
Sanders Demaryius Thomas Chris Harris
jr. and Bradley Roby might all be on the
Block ooh
yeah Emmanuel Sanders - I I hope not for
the Broncos fans yes because I think
Emmanuel Sanders is a number one in this
league yeah I didn't really do yeah but
Demaryius Thomas you could see them
parting ways right I mean it fits the
whole mold of like what we talked about
with backup quarterbacks he's not even
the second best receiver on their team
anymore that goes to Cameron Sutton
Court Courtland Courtland sorry I don't
know why I was gonna call him Cameron
Courtland Sutton is the guy that is
number two for me when I watch their
team I go ooh this guy special yes you
can't play a man-to-man he can run by
you or 50/50 ball you Demaryius Thomas
has definitely lost a step he's still
good he can still get open yeah but
he's at this point of his career just a
real good - he's no longer in the class
for a number one and yeah I think if you
trade for him something like this and
you say okay we're gonna actually give
you a little value mid-round pic or
something like that they might want to
hear something about him renegotiating
you can get out of his deal I got it in
front of me at least for next year if
you did trade him he takes a 17 million
dollar cap hit but if they cut him it's
a 3.5 million where teams could probably
deal with that and they see latest
report on Demaryius is that the Broncos
are not actively shopping him but
they'll listen if teams call yeah uh
LeSean McCoy a lot of Eagles fans when
they heard LeSean McCoy they go now he
doesn't have it anymore and I try to
explain him how bad the Buffalo Bills
offensive line and quarterback situation
is yes and whatever he's done thus far
isn't a fair representation right to get
banged up last game also has some
off-the-field issues that are still up
in the air yeah but how much do you
think LeSean McCoy has left to go and
possibly make a trade for I think that
it's like next year could be his last
real quality year like you might get
like nine good starts out of him yeah
it's it's it's kinda Jo Jo
well yeah the the body definitely does
not look quite the same like he's
starting I don't want to say will wilt
withering away but not just as rocked up
and as thick as you see as you start to
see guys they lose their arms they lose
their ass and legs a little bit still as
quickness still has value that way but
yeah I don't expect to see the LeSean
McCoy that you saw last year or two
years ago I think you could just see a
guy now that you want in your rotation
but you don't want him to be your
workhorse
Devante Parker's agent called Adam GaSe
incompetence
yeah I'm Adam GaSe said well Albert
Wilson and Kenny Stills around I guess
we have to play Devante Parker yeah what
where is Devante Parker in your mind
former first-round pick another player
out of Louisville shows a lot of
potential going deep banged up almost
constantly constantly is this somebody
that you would make a move for if you
were a team if the price was right I
would be good route like six seventh
round pick yeah you know maybe even for
a guy like this fifth round at that
point I mean he's he's doesn't have a
lot of my
Jonah's tires he would kind of fall into
the class of okay Amari Cooper where I
think maybe he just needs a scenery
change to like kind of jumpstart things
which was the thing in Miami yeah it
definitely is it seems like not
everybody can handle gazes realness and
in-your-face attitude which he has but
sighs very good route runner and when
healthy can run by you
I mean don't be shocked this we could we
see two if you see
Devante performance architects yes yet
like ninety or a hundred yards day of
receiving he's he has that type of
ability there was a lot of teams that
really liked him coming out in the dress
and I wouldn't be shocked to see well
it's not gonna happen right now what do
you mean oh because of all the injuries
they're not gonna they're not going to
abandon ship what do we think about Adam
GaSe right now that Jarvis Landry and
AMA can sue a Pouncy brother these
fights with with Devante Parker now
we're in common denominator section
right what's the common denominator of
all these issues Adam GaSe yeah and I
understand and I know that you respect
that on gas a lot I think he's a really
good coach why is he rubbing some what
what could he possibly be doing that
other football coaches the NFL are not
doing to get in people's heads I just I
don't think he politics or Susan soothes
soothes things over with players right
he just Adam GaSe fan over here yeah he
just he's not into that he's not gonna
like placate to your ego and oj-- Arvest
you're so great and o our offense
wouldn't work without you no no fourteen
million dollars a years is too much for
you you know for what seventy bubble
screens yeah you know what I mean so I
think that's where the pushback comes
from you know again sue I don't know
what to tell you they're Sue's always
been like that to a degree yeah he
probably needed to go to another place
where they go like like we talk like the
New England Factor like wow they're good
they don't really mean me here hmm
they're gonna be good no matter what and
I'm not even the best of my position on
this team so that'll make you step in
the line to just like gasps and Gruden
are in a similar thing where they're
like emptying out the half filled tank
to fill it up again
speaking of glory Gary and Conley but
the differences gays
doesn't BS and Gruden's gotten caught in
BS like four different times this year
mmm aisle we're not mari Cooper's not on
the trade block you just said that seven
days ago I'm I know the tray we're not
trading to Amari Cooper traded gone Zia
oh well I never believed any of the
quote that's honestly why I don't even
pay that much attention to press
conferences yeah I I guess it's it's a
lot of [ __ ] when it who is the
honest one you know and also what would
Bill Belichick do not pay attention to
press conferences yeah yeah I get you
Gary and Connelly right you think you
think the Raiders would move him I don't
know who would want him at this point
that's there's been that bad yeah he's
not good Oh Gary and Connelly who loved
Gary in college yeah Gary and Connelly
runs a forever right now I don't even
know what he runs okay it's it's not
ever since he's dealt with shin splints
and even they're in the training camp
this year he couldn't practice because
he had some other lower body issue that
gear that I saw in college it's not
there right now
damn Kerry Connelly an OB melon fun with
the two biggest misses of Chris Simms
career John I know I still feel good at
that OB where is OB they just they just
released him he's been on IR oh god yeah
he's another one hasn't been healthy at
all right I got one more name for you
jus Norris Jenkins yeah this is another
former prime time corner I know you've
taken them a step back but could you see
a lot of teams clamoring for the fire
sale that is the New York Giants range I
do think I do think there could be some
teams that would want to get into that
bed but generous they go you know we're
close here we need one extra guy just to
be able to man it down in certain
situations yeah it's not been a great
year for generous and last year wasn't
great either
now you look at his money he's due to
make 14 million dollars next year with a
seven million dollar cap it so that's
going to play into it and I would say
yeah but if I'm like the Chiefs or
something yeah those are the it's going
it's worthy a team like that yeah right
but they're gonna have to do their
homework on the individual I mean about
going back to college they're gonna have
to investigate people with the Giants to
go like what's the real deal here I mean
if his brother allegedly murders
somebody in their house that's a
months-long process leading
up to the draft yeah and now right now
you would have to do it in seven days
yeah you listen right now what would
really happen though is this is like
most smart franchises and I say most to
Patriots the Patriots for sure they
would have a list of guys like in the
computer in a document to go we'd have
to start making tapes like four weeks
ago we could see them maybe trade in
these guys these guys might be timeout
okay so we're gonna live in there so
you're telling me yeah that if you were
working with the Patriots right now in
your position where you worked in an
office with no windows and you would be
sent there with a thirty like cell
spreadsheet right that about in week
three or four they came to you and said
we could see these guys being traded on
these teams they don't say that to me
but like let's say in my time they're
like a John Robinson or a Bob Quinn they
would have been like hey guys there's a
new there's a new there's a new tab in
the blah blah blah document we need
tapes of all those guys by like you know
next week sometime no rush no rush it's
only like a hundred guys that which is
clearly the trade list
clearly it's a hundred guys all around
the league I'm just yeah it could be
like let's just say three or four guys
from every team where they go ooh this
could make sense we've kind of sat in
some meetings and gone maybe they could
be up for grabs maybe they want to move
on making trade was anyone that you were
that you guys made videos of oh that
year we traded for a keep to leave and
yeah I mean I don't think I didn't make
that video no but I'm sure somebody did
because Bill's gonna do is dude know
England is already making tapes for cap
casualties for next offseason I can
promise you what do you mean
like guys that they're looking at
they're going they might have one more
year in their deal and they're getting
up there in age we wanted you to start
making tapes of them as the season goes
on because one people on other teams
yeah yeah and that's you know I think
that's common not to that extent no no
definitely not
did you say one time to us that the
scouts won't always put all the plays on
a tape of a draft prospect because they
want their
piñon of them - well I I do yes at times
yes like there was biased in some
people's tapes where I was like damn I
watched that game and they didn't put
like four plays that I would have put on
that tape
does that happen with the NFL players -
yeah it definitely does as far as like
them yeah I mean because we talk about
bias it's a real thing that's why I like
okay if you're a smart coach again like
Bill Belichick he's gonna look at these
tapes but he's not gonna be like well
I'm gonna trust old Johnny boy up on the
third floor this tapes pretty good he's
pretty awesome I'm gonna I'm gonna go
trade for this guy
he's no look at that tape and go oh
there's some things that interest me
here now let me put in two whole games
and I'm gonna watch the games and see
what he is from there yeah dude people
get called out for their bias nobody's a
lot of times they don't know and it
won't matter always for a guy like Bill
in New England because they're gonna do
their due diligence they're not just
gonna go off the oh here's 60 play tape
of you know Johnny Scout who's been out
of college for two years just made and
we're gonna believe his tape is the true
story well I can almost guarantee you
that in the next 70 days those tapes
dude it sounds awful I mean I have one
more how to make how to how to make
arrows pointing at the guy every play ah
because like Bill didn't want to waste
time like where is he what socks is he
got on look I'm gonna be honest as the
Bill Belichick of this podcast I
understand yeah yeah yeah before you ask
your question the trade deadline is next
Tuesday yeah I can almost guarantee that
Bill Belichick will trade for a
linebacker by next Tuesday
it is a yearly staple he collects
linebackers randomly during the trade
deadline because he believes like
running backs those positions get hurt
the most and he tries to accumulate as
many as possible so that they can stand
the test of time yes he's done it year
in and year out he may trace the Lions
last year for a linebacker position for
him he's not gonna let like it's like
the same thing with the running back or
the slot receiver he's not gonna let one
injury at that position go our whole
scheme screwed because now we've lost
that one guy like he's not gonna let
that happen so yeah he is going to
collect those type of
fires because the van noise and the
atlantean Rafael van Noy yeah all them
they fit what he wants to do and they
can do multiple things so then all in a
given week we need to use more
linebackers this week you know this week
I need this linebacker to play outside
instead of inside and that's why he does
though the docks yeah Microsoft Word or
Google Docs and are they
password-protected oh yeah it's like a
whole new england patriots security
system that you have to log into and
they're tracking everything you're doing
definitely yes right Microsoft Word or
Google
oh no Microsoft microscopy sees Excel no
max not not a startup no definitely not
that's all I got I just want to know
about the docs yeah yeah use staplers
my read Steve do they print a lot of
stuff yes they have a lot of shredders I
feel like yes the playbook crap I've
like oh my gosh I got to do the handouts
on Wednesday morning at George gasps see
me would be like let's go get the [ __ ]
down here I mean we got like five
thousand copies to make and I'd be doing
them and it first have to go pass them
around to the coaches and do all that
and yes they used to waste so much paper
I told you this is this is because of me
and a Tom bonding smile cuz you were
like your wife is pretty I was like dude
after like week seven and I was like me
and Tom are comfortable that I think he
knows he probably hates me now but then
we were cool and I was like giving them
a huge packet of paper I'm like a
Wednesday morning I'm like and he's like
man we really use a lot of paper and I
think I know I was like I can't believe
it I was like your poor wife's country
and he looked at me and I was like yup
we just took down half the rain forests
of Brazil and he looked at me and he
smiled it's like you're right you're
right and so the next week next year the
next year iPad it's always iPads and I
always like like to think that Tom went
into mr. Kraft it was like we are
ruining my wise home country I just
imagine that he's like at home
stir-frying lima beans and he's like hey
Giselle this intern nerd came up with a
pretty good joke about your country that
I just can't imagine
you being a professional athlete and
then the very next year being that guy
that prints out 5000 copies and hands
out the papers you could write like talk
about reality check like for me be
getting paid eighteen five and living in
the middle of Nebraska and covering
local city council meetings and like
going to the local watering hole after
the news and drinking a beer and going
what the [ __ ] am i doing or making
similar money
ya know what were you making twenty
twenty yeah is making eighty five right
yeah but you're really in Boston and
living in Boston I was living you're
like a sweet doubt housing honey every
month I was there yeah I won't lie mr.
Kraft a few times during the year he's
like subji hundred dollar handshake ah I
wish he a few times when you like it was
a Friday or a Monday and there was the
players and mr. Kraft is I mean he's an
amazing owner I would put him up there
against anybody he's got a great feel
for sounds like just the DNA of the
organization and he makes sure he goes
around and talks to people and shows his
appreciation for what you're doing and
that's where he's really special but
yeah there was a few days during that
year where he came in he saw me grinding
away and it was just me and him in like
a meeting room and he's like you sure
you want to do this you sure you're not
like these guys they're not yours he's
that he said this even those guys you're
star I think you're a star you sure you
want to do this I like this I gotta do
it I think he was referring to I think
he was referring to do I'd really want
to be grinded in the ground curmudgeon
for the next 20 years of my life what
was your dad saying you during that
point it's all part of the process
Christopher yeah oh hey hey head down
you made it to Friday you got the
weekend survived I mean would you just
come home with Danielle just be like
what the hell am i doing no I really
wasn't it started to get there like that
with her where she was just like gosh I
mean are we ever gonna see you I thought
like and March we'd get to see you more
and I was like well you know it'll ask
for another round of tea we got the
draft coming up and free agency coming
up and I just started to wear wear her
out it'll warm me out only from the
simple fact
that I felt like I was missing my kids
growing up that's the only thing that's
right when I see these people it's it's
easy to question coaches but the ones
that you know are really grinding and
the ones that are really working hard
it's it's a crazy life that they yeah
and that's why when I was joking earlier
about Hugh Jackson that's why the
biggest insult you can have for a coach
is they're not working hard yeah right
because it's the implied notion of what
everyone went through and the hours
they've given away in the days and the
weeks they sacrifice right that if
you're accused of not it's like the
worse or you can say don't ever and as
we know and we've we talked about we
talked about it earlier today I mean
there's just there's nobody that's out
gonna out-compete the New England
Patriots coaching staff on a weekly
basis there's just no you're gonna have
to really put it in you got to take it
to a new level because they're on a new
level and you're gonna run a new level
Simms can't say new level without doing
no but they are and it's not just then
it's like I said March April May it's
all of it so you had experience with
Bill Belichick and the Patriots and I
also believe you are uniquely uniquely
qualified to talk about what's happening
with the Raiders and cry gate derrick
karr possibly seen crying on the field
after getting hit by the Seattle
Seahawks yeah reports come out that the
team has lost confidence in Derek Carr
after hearing him quote Wimmer on the
field by the way not many verbs
[Music]
did you cry when your spleen exploded no
okay you've got another town I haven't
cried I paid three more quarters yeah my
first reaction is I haven't liked ride
with something that hurt me
you just yell like the F word yeah like
I go crazy if something hurts I know
yeah like have you ever seen a player
cry on the field I can't say that I have
I can't say that I was ever on a field
where somebody cried he is denying the
cry ah he should because I haven't seen
a video where that justifies that
college and one still image of his eyes
tightly packed right and and he's
listening together right he's first got
hurt and he's he's asking somebody to
help him up yeah crying does happen but
it happens for like Jason Peters last
year when he knows you realize a year
and my team is really good and this is
heartbreaking it's more realization not
like oh my knee hurts I'm crying cuz it
hurts so much mommy it hurts it's more
like they're on the back of a car it's
like damn man it's I this is the year
we're good and I'm and I'm playing good
and why did this have to happen that
that's the crying that goes on the NFL
so do you believe this her do you no I
do not believe it I do not and I think
the thing with Derek Carr first of all
you can't really question him at this
point but that Harper a broken back and
all that back I mean he broke his leg
and was like miked up for the game two
years right he was like go away oh he
was like he's like all it's broke it's
broke remember I mean he wasn't like oh
it's broke yeah he was like it's broke
he was like go out there and win so
matter of fact right yeah okay so he's
played through a number of injuries I do
think there's one conversation that
plays into this okay and again it's the
God Squad thing gosh I have no problem
with religion I'm just trying to say
that everybody out there you have said
this for a long time that in the
construct of the locker room there are
different factions and one of those
factions is Peep
that are very religious right bring
religion into the locker room on a
consistent basis Derrick Brooks was one
of those guys you play exactly right
Derrick Brooks
I mean hey listen there's been plenty of
God squatters that are awesome players
Derrick Brooks Reggie White oh yeah I
mean I don't get any more better at that
I think Reggie White invented the prayer
circle after gain see I think I think
you're exactly right I think he did and
um so again not that there's anything
wrong and most guys in a locker room our
religious guys but they don't
necessarily bring it in there all the
time right yeah they're gonna go to
church on Sunday mom and dad raise them
right but it doesn't mean they come in
and going like god bless you Adam left
go and and there were guys in locker
room that would do that there's
definitely certain guys in a locker room
yes that are going to be you know I'm
pushing that narrative hey do you want
to go to after after practice day we're
gonna have a Bible study in the DB room
you want to come in and for Bible study
you know or you know the Bible study you
guys are gonna go over and do something
at a church later do you want to be a
part of that gotcha and hey look I know
Carson Wentz Jordan Matthews Zach Ertz
they're part of one of those exactly
right so nothing wrong with that but my
only thing would be this just to say and
I'm talking about I'm just giving
everybody a look at an NFL locker room
and how I've been around in my whole
life and I've been there and the guys
and just my experience with even hearing
these conversations so it's one thing if
you're Derrick Brooks and you're a god
swatter and you're balling out and
you're an all-pro tackle and Michael
Vick and open space and you know you
know body slam and TJ Duquette nobody's
gonna question you but when you are that
guy also and you don't perform on the
field and it's a sport of 53 alpha males
and they all want to see like the phrase
I would say most got got to see that dog
in you got to see that dog in you you
got some dog in you cuz if you don't got
some dog in you I don't know if I want
to get in the hole and fight with you
right so that part of it takes it and if
you're too nice and always you know you
know
god bless this god bless that blah blah
blah you're saying that a lot of people
see that as not having dog have it not
having dog having is funny that dog in
God or reverse direct but have
having it neither here nor there you're
right it actually is funny but yes
having a softness about you per se right
which isn't necessarily accurate but it
is the way it's person it's not because
in the other song room yeah they want
you know renegades
usually run the locker room the renegade
who's like a [ __ ] that we're gonna do
this yes let's go drink a beer after to
fair or not that's no men's men look at
each other right yeah you know we had a
beer together I could trust them and
ever since Derek Carr and dad died and I
think people sometimes don't think they
can relate to it and then makes you
question all he's not playing well and
he got a few dicey decisions in a big
moment as he a wimp yeah you know is he
a wimp cuz he can't do this and they
build on that character exact see my
thing would be less that and more now
I'm going to the rumor that was last
year right Washington game Raiders go
there right after the kneel a kneeling
thing with Trump right and there was the
rumor that car fought back in the locker
room about not kneeling and it upset his
offensive line and there was this whole
like conversation on the internet about
did the offensive line purposely let
Derek Carr get sacked a lot because they
felt that he disrespected them I am NOT
trying to bring validity to that
discussion yeah I am saying it's weird
to me then in back-to-back seasons
there's a rumor of his offensive line
hating him because of race related
issues and now there's a rumor of him
being a wimp and crying on the field I'm
just going I'm not even saying where
there's smoke there's fire right I'm
just going why do people keep coming
after Derek Carr it's the easy thing his
brother his brother was kind of labeled
as always jumping in the pocket he's not
the toughest guy ever
meanwhile the worst offensive line ever
created in front of them but hey they're
here exactly I know but you're exactly
right and they drafted Tony Boselli like
number one in the expansion draft that
he never played yeah he was done his
career was over right so I think all
those things play into it and when
you're too perfect and at the locker
room that ain't a good thing either
everybody wants to see a full
they want to see oh he drinks beers he
swears too much mmm he smokes pot right
that'll actually give you some like you
know what he does he's a [ __ ] guy
right kind of like that like he you know
he could say he can say that in certain
situations right and just do it and not
necessarily that I'm not saying that's
redeeming qualities or anything like
that but I'm just saying that's the the
element of the locker room it's the same
reason that we pick apart people like JJ
Watt because perfect people seem not
possible right half the time I watch the
rock
I look at him and I go wow you're
incredible and the other half of me is
going there's no way this guy's like
something about you is lying because we
understand that humans themselves are in
perfect right and if you're gonna bring
it to religion I mean that's like the
number one thing in religion is you are
filled with sin thus you need God right
so that's why it is funny that we look
at athletes and and Derek Carr I guess
is one of those perfect guys you know
yes
quarterback of a team super fun-loving
never says the wrong thing maybe but
it's I don't know I don't know why
everyone keeps coming at Derek Carr yeah
you don't think the Raiders are trading
and I don't think so I mean they're
coming at them too because his damn
coach came at him first I mean his coach
kind of Amari Cooper was open a few
times I don't know why I didn't throw it
here our quarterbacks been pressing so
he opened the floodgates to a degree and
then of course now the team's unhappy
because Amari Cooper gets traded during
practice and the coach doesn't even talk
to the team I think that John Wooden not
understanding how social media works and
I really think he was like I don't need
to talk about Amari Cooper being traded
but as long as I get to him before the
morning newspaper comes out like I don't
think Gruden's on Twitter I don't think
Gruden's on Instagram he doesn't
understand this new news cycle he
probably went they're not gonna find out
meanwhile John they all got to the
locker room they had the BR app with a
notification with 17,000 people weighing
in on it and they saw him pulled off the
field at practice oh my god so when a
Peyer like Amari Cooper gets pulled off
the field at practice
you need to stop practice what do you
mean you need to stop it
you need to go come around to Mir team
come here
we had a trade Amari Cooper we did hey
we didn't want to but Dallas made us an
offer that we just really could not
refuse at this time and I just wanted
you guys to find out for me before we
got in the locker room and he looked on
the phone and those are the things
that's what a like a leader of a team
has to do the players just want to be
shot straight just like we've always
talked about
and when you've the pliers here the head
coach go we're not trading Amari Cooper
oh he's not on the trade block and then
six days later he gets traded your word
don't mean [ __ ] exactly right and
especially then when you avoid to
actually give them your word and
confront the situation when it happens
that's the biggest issue with Cruden
right that's it my issue with Gruden is
not that he tore it all down right to be
honest I actually find it admirable yeah
when someone has the confidence to go
what we have here is good it's not gonna
win the Superbowl
we're gonna tear it down and start over
so what my Sixers did until I understand
that right I appreciate having the guts
to take all of the brunt about trading a
Kaleo Mac and trading an Amari Cooper
and accumulating three first-round picks
right my problem is is that when you
tear it down you're building a
foundation but there's two foundations
there's a foundation of players and
there's a foundation of concept and
there's a foundation of what you stand
for and what Gruden has given us thus
far is the okey doke yeah like Gruden
has not been honest with us at all but
if he stood at that microphone and said
we weren't ready we're here not to beat
the Chiefs we're here to beat the
Patriots and the Packers and win Super
Bowls we'd sit there and go damn like I
can't argue with that yeah but it's the
lying
it's the sneakiness that's the part
where I go that's the foundation that
you've put 10 years right and a hundred
million dollars on and we'll be moving a
franchise on the back of a guy that's
not shooting it straight that's my issue
with Google I think that's the I think
your issue is probably exactly why
you're hearing some of these veteran
players say that because they're the
same they're thinking the same thing you
like that you are there go start the
draft that's what I'm calling Donald
Penn ya draft to Colton Miller's gonna
fire you up
it's write stuff like that or how we got
some veterans to come
the town I'm sure hey we got something
here we're gonna be competitive this
sherek child cut some right all of them
you know there's just there's frosty
rucker whatever all these guys who were
going i'm up there in my years in my
career here i only get a few years left
and he told me we were gonna try to win
this year and it looked to them like
they've done everything but the opposite
of that I know what it's like to look
into a veteran's eyes when I when a
player gets traded and then get upset
when I sat on that roof with Malcolm
Jenkins and they treated Sam Bradford
for a first-round pick he got really
upset not because he didn't believe in
Carson Wentz like we didn't like know
what was good
no yeah but he said to me verbatim I
came here because I thought they had a
chance to win and in practice Sam gives
us the best chance to win right Amari
Cooper gives them the best chance to win
Khaleel Matt gives them the best chance
to win and so for those veterans it's
like a shot in the chest
yes Colin McCullough a commenter on
YouTube wrote this I'm curious on your
take not our Colin McCullough here at
Bleacher I was gonna say well yeah the
same name maybe it is the same guy I
think he spells it differently this
guy's with a you okay
are we convinced Gruden's type of player
exists anymore I feel like he wants big
personality hard-working grinders this
is an outside perspective but it seems
as a fan that there are way more
glassy-eyed robotic Amari Cooper's out
there in the old Bucks legends he
doesn't like any of the guys on his team
more like he doesn't like the modern NFL
player what do you think I I think
there's some truth to that I think he
still holds on to the 90s renegade era
where yeah we can just accumulate as
many guys and salary caps not an issue
and who cares if you're a badass and
you've got in trouble you know social
media all those things weren't there at
that time to kind of call you out so
yeah he came from a team with the
Raiders that was like that of course he
took over for the Bucs who were like
that
the Eagles team before that when he was
the OC I'm sure you had a few running
games on that oh yeah rightly so
so yes it's the era in which he grew up
in and now
he's having to deal with guys who were
very self-aware very aware of the league
in general because of alerts popping up
on their phone like yours every four
seconds and are also even worse to that
in his case they're they're aware
business-wise as far as what's going on
in the league and he just wants you to
go he just wants to go I'll run the team
just believe in me and we'll go from
here and that day's gun that doesn't
happen anymore and that's why I always
try to stay - so I Bill Belichick go
once once again back to WWB BD is he's
much more of a player's coach than
people realize and why is that because
it's a player's league you can't mess
with that still at the end of the day
bill knows I gotta stay in the good
graces of the players if I want players
to come here if I want the players to
stay happy and continue to take to my
coaching and do the little things you
know that we want the really good
players to do so I gotta have some
conversation some real talk with them so
I'm opening my heart so they'll open
their heart to me all of those things
and the day of the you know Gruden evil
dictator way that's that's dying it's
dead look at Shaun McVeigh I mean Shaun
McVeigh he's not running an evil
dictatorship he's like we're a
meritocracy his best idea wins
exactly exactly right and just follow me
and I'll give you the energy you guys
need and you know I'm in here working
and I'm kid genius and let's go and who
says I can't say what's up man and have
a beer with you later on tonight does
that make me less of a football coach no
[ __ ] you Robert Woods is still open for
a 30-yard game later next week and Todd
Gurley still ran from 150 yeah and I
think that's just the old regime still
clashing with the new regime what's
funny as though it's like Bella checks
been all of the regimes yes we don't
have an issue with him yeah because he
adapts and II read his quote unquote the
old regime he adapts he's been wise
enough Andy Reid could have a running
back fumble 15 times in one game to go
that was my fault
that's my fault he fumbled cuz of me I
ate an extra hotdog on Wednesday
and I made the balls a little slippery
and he had just I didn't give him the
best chance like he always always right
yeah I mean never it's always I didn't
give us it and Pires love that and
that's why Andy Reid even when [ __ ]
falls apart
you don't ever hear them go like damn
I'm glad we got Andy out of town yeah
this just makes me think back to last
week of you standing at the line of
scrimmage and the linebackers standing
right where you thought he was supposed
to be and then you throw the ball and
come over and it's your fault that the
whole game plan was wrong and everything
you prepared for it right right you told
me the Blitz is gonna come to the side
for the linebackers on the line it's
courage they're both on me and the line
of scrimmage I'm gonna have to redo my
owner rant again soon because really
it's not John Gruden's fault no it's not
all his fault if I was offered 10 years
a hundred million hell yeah I'd coach
too the problem is is that Mark Davis is
the son of Al Davis which means he
didn't create his own legacy and thus
you are chasing the dreams of your
father I've seen it time and time again
and the dream of his father was to have
Jon Gruden coach the problem was that
was a dream 10 years ago right and so
what happened was is we're living in a
2008 offense in a 2018 world I think
there's definitely some truth to that
John I'm not giving up on John with this
yet I'm not I'm just gonna tell you that
I'm just trying to say that because John
is still psycho in a good way and still
gonna go to the lab every day I have
more confidence in John next year when
John took a year of beat up a year of
like being destroyed the media's big
thing is he has to stop worrying about
saving face on week two of the NFL
season just take the blunt your take the
blood of the criticism your 10 years of
hunting off the advantage of having a
10-year career who cares exactly right
in your contract you don't need to say
like oh my player could have done this
or my player could have done that that's
what's gonna make the team look at him
in a bad way yeah exactly if anyone
should take all the blame it's John
right stop playing the newspapers or in
your world John Instagram its new it's a
thing it's really out there all right
let's talk about Belichick we're gonna
start a book of Sims isms I think I'm
gonna start writing them all
take the blunt of the criticism what was
the other one you like to read in
between the tea leaves the brunt of the
criticisms believe ya I can't believe
he's got a dirty mind people people
loved you out Baltimore Baltimore trying
to be Baltimore in Baltimore that was a
good one felt like what was the other
one about a bunch of yeah a bunch of
people sent to us I'll go back and
there's another meme that was sent to us
today about the team Oh media's of the
member yeah yeah you're talking to all
the media's of the member which sounds
like press covering a alright so you
went back and look to the film and the
first one I have here is Bears Patriots
submersed Patriots offense Bears defense
first little star here Pats coaches let
the players break in with the game
easily yeah well it's a little bit about
what I texted you during the game right
like the first Drive just if you go back
and I'm gonna pull up the plays too just
so we can talk to it real quick so I can
really be specific about it because I
think it's worth it but this is what
good coaches do this is what the Sean
mcveigh's the Kyle Shanahan's
you know the Bill Belichick's whoever it
may be they know how to start a football
game and build confidence with their
football team as we go on so here we go
okay first buy the game Sony Michelle
right off the right tackle 18 yards next
play short pass - did I write all these
down hello me just make sure I didn't
okay I did I wrote them down anyways
alright so here we go
runs the ball perfectly good run then
it's a play-action screen same kind of
run that they just ran for 18 yards I'm
gonna fake that run and now we're gonna
throw a screen nice play now get in the
shotgun totally different look it's
spread out we're passing screen again
great double screen doubles so two
screens in a row now it's getting the
empty formation we're an empty nobody's
there he motions James White to come
back in he's underneath the center as
they're in empty and he tosses them the
ball behind him and they run like a toss
crack to the left side okay all in this
I just wanted to let everybody know
they're driving down the field for a
touchdown then it's up the middle run
then it's empty
short pass Edelman then it's shotgun
screen again the blitz gets there so he
has to throw it into the ground it
becomes em complete so he throws it away
now it's third in one and okay hey it
looks like they're gonna run it up the
middle again with Sonia Michelle nope
there's three receivers to the left he
throws the screen after Julian Edelman
they get the first down and he gets the
touchdown right there so there it is I
feel like if you're the Bears defense
you're sitting there on the sidelines
going what the hell just happened
exactly right exactly the defense is
what do we even focus on exactly left go
they hit me with the screen they hit my
run up the middle the himmat the quick
throw they me with the wide receiver
screen they hit me with the jet sweep
from the running backs on the play what
are we even keel exactly so the players
are going I don't really know what
happened and then they're going over to
the sideline at going and I hope our
coaches can tell us and the coaches are
going I'm not sure how they're trying to
attack us yet because they just did
everything but he just did everything
right so I don't know at all what the
game plan is yet do they do this most
games yes they usually do yes they
you're talking about like spreading a
team's out it's just like that yes just
digging when everybody I don't know why
every team doesn't do screens on the
first run well they do like Sean Payton
does you'll say he did it the focus my
thing would be if there's one time the
defense is really gonna pin their ears
back right away as a guy yeah you're
like I'm gonna get Brady and atone but
now your team really did nothing
physically special they just executed
plays yeah but nobody had to be like
Brady didn't have to be like I gotta
throw a 40-yard laser or you know the
the big receiver who scored Josh Gordon
he didn't have to make some crazy catch
and you did right though about Josh
Gordon his speed is starting to show and
Brady loves him his route running is
very impressive you talked about this on
Monday yeah I mean if the tape even like
shows it it really does yeah Burton
there's a big moment Brady is getting
into thee I'm looking for Josh Gordon
kind of mode I mean and why should he
not because the way he runs and controls
his body especially I still think he's
out you just saw this happening for
months but yeah it's it's starting to
look pretty it's just really annoying
when the Patriots signed someone you go
I bet you they turn this guy into the
most important part of their offense and
take over the NFL and then it happens
you did right though on the opposite
side yeah
Khaleel Mac you wrote is a useless
useless he was just you might as well
put Adam left go out there he can't do
anything I know that's a little unfair
to me yeah what do you mean how is
Khalil make useless he's in our top-five
MVP can why I'm just saying his ankle
was bad and it's probably a lot worse
than they've let it like let on for all
of us to believe Wow he's got nothing he
has no explosion off the line of
scrimmage he can't push anybody back but
the only thing he can do is hold to the
ground and set the edge on the run game
so he's not losing ground he's not
gaining ground he's just he's just out
there pretty much every tech he's fine
right exactly right he's just playing
football but he's not Khalil Mac as we
know it right now for the last two weeks
so you've really been noticing this oh
it's really hampered their defense
without a doubt I mean their game plan
was correct if they had a Khalil Mac
healthy what do you mean because they
played smart coverages played man-to-man
and all the right situations oh it's
third and three you think you're gonna
throw one of these Edelman Dinkin
dunkers or is we're gonna have a guy on
a man-to-man and a linebacker in that
area ready to go no but they just
couldn't get the pass rush and there was
not existent the whole game I know I'm
disappointing the guys like Leonard
Floyd I don't know where he's gone as a
pass rusher but yes that's what kind of
player Khalil Mack is and as we know
when you want to beat the Patriots when
you could do it with your front four and
keep everybody in coverage that's when
you can beat him how much longer do you
think this is gonna be this one like the
way it looks I bet you another three
weeks Wow yeah bet the kids the Bears
it's definitely and Khalil Mack being
quote useless at this point white I mean
I don't mean like what what how much
does that change their defense I just
think it's gonna make Vic Fangio go with
certain situations and certain quarter
axes and I goddamn I can't really play
the defense I want to play I might have
to bring two or three people now he even
did that a few times during the game he
knew Coolio Mac couldn't rush the passer
so there was a few third downs and
obvious passing situations where Coolio
Mac dropped out he dropped out they send
somebody in there's still a four-man
rush but yeah he's really just a body
out there and a shell of himself right
now alright so I have all your notes in
front of me for the Bears offense and
for the Patriots defense I'm gonna bring
up I'm just gonna let every
know that I I listen to the mic Lombardi
podcast and he is dead set that true
Biscay is not a quarterback right in the
film yeah I hear ya I mean I know I've
heard him say that where do you stand
I don't stand that strong yet no I'd
like to see more calm he came in on
Monday and a lot of people were in that
meeting room that wasn't that movie
because I just don't find true Biscay
impressive yeah um I've been a true
Biscay defender I don't I don't think I
can defend him in this game that's for
sure this is his worst game of the year
yeah seeing the field quality of the
football like I always talked about I'm
not into like oh he was 26 of 50 I don't
give a damn I mean if you're 26 for 50
and on those 24 incompletions nobody was
freaking open and you threw the ball
where you were aiming for and putting it
in safe places and just as incomplete
then that's not a bad quarterback play
but when there's people open and tarik
cones running down the sidelines do you
throw the ball three yards out of bounds
and I see the balls wobbling everywhere
and then I see six or seven throws like
that as the game goes on to continue
even more yeah and then some bad
decisions along with it
that is when I go okay this is this is
not a good day he's missing open
receivers he's not seeing some of them
he's missing the throws of some of them
he should he threw two picks you know he
had three or four dropped the two picks
were actually amazing catches incredible
incredible catches but it was like
football gods were like well you should
already throw it for we've dropped him
so we got to give you two okay
but yes it was I understand what Mike's
saying there cuz sure Brisky is on that
fine line of what you and I talk about
right is he a quarterback who's a good
athlete or he's an athlete who plays
quarterback what are we call it again
and fake cubies fake cubies and he might
be I'm not saying these not in the
Tannehill but I don't think it's very
early to say that and I do think some of
the criticism early on in the year was
unfair because of that too but yeah I
can't defend him after this game on the
others you said that the Patriots really
couldn't defend his running game either
no that was the one thing that they were
not I don't think they thought like he's
gonna run like that on us they were like
let's stay in our pass rush lanes but
they didn't keep a spy or it's not until
late in the game it's a real weapon for
him oh he can really was a true athlete
he really is New England's defense yeah
a Landon Roberts being back he wrote
down his huge yeah and Jackson number 27
yeah JC Jackson JC Jackson yeah
Maryland Maryland kid I think he got
some off-the-field troubles but you
wrote that he's better than Devin
McCourty yes not not not well we I meant
Jason McCord he didn't okay cuz that's
why I started re
sorry yes I wrote 30 and then I wrote
Devin McCourty wait so yes who's the
safety Jason Devin Jason's the corner
damn I'm confused I know these are
Tigers my whole life and I still can't
figure it out ah so he's better than
Jason right Jason starts the game at
corner
JC Jackson is a special athlete and he
jumped out in the draft process to me
but I can't remember and you might have
to look it up
III want to say he got kicked out of a
school out of school for getting in
trouble somewhere but six 190 pounds I
mean can play man-to-man can go and gets
his hands on you know the line of
scrimmage good luck but yeah I think
with him and Jonathan Jones and
Nickelback that's their best secondary
it gives him two really legit athletes
all the jobs have one of those crazy
pick he did they both there was both of
them with the picks
Jason thought it was Eddie Jackson ya
know is JC Jackson who got that with his
right arm there that was that was
incredible but he's a player to watch
out for and the point with the island
and Roberts thing is and Landon Roberts
is their most athletic linebacker right
he's the guy that can run sideline to
sideline so it doesn't make them have to
play Hightower there all the time I
think New England's at their best when
Roberts is in the middle and they can
use Hightower on the edge as an outside
linebacker deal it's really the same way
went to Florida was charged with fork
for felony charges for armed robbery
declared not guilty and that went to
Mara but so that was the issue that's
why he went undrafted because I'm just
telling you from the draft process this
guy was a first three rounds type of
talent I mean he
6 1 190 I want to say he ran like lo
four fours at the combine Josh yep I
want to say I was like that for a
four-for-one something like that but
he's a player alright I want to go to
Ravens 6-4 6-4 4-6 okay Ravens Saints
one of my favorite things we're gonna
start right here meme town how come
Flacco does nothing on the Wildcat and
it becomes an internet joke but when
Brees does it it's okay he said what
happened so it was Brees to her the same
thing that Flacco did I mean when Taysom
Hill runs the ball he stands there and
watches the play but again this is not
an attack on Drew Brees no it's more of
a joke blacoh our psyche of America I
just don't know that's what it says you
know the Flacco thing was a hole on the
internet everyone watch because like I
feel like somebody in the office showed
me on Monday video yes we put it up and
maybe it was I think that's where I
first saw it you put it up on Sunday
night on Instagram yeah I think my wife
is yeah I get it it is hilarious and it
looks crazed up yeah but it's screwed up
and every other quarterback who gets put
in that situation does exactly what Joe
Flacco does but because it's Joe Flacco
and for some reason it's easy to jump on
him let's make it an internet thing yeah
when I could show you ten plays Taysom
Hill running the ball and nobody it's oh
I mean just that bat crap bothers me in
this business it bothers me like oh you
don't get the benefit of the doubt but
you're cool standing out there doing
nothing what I don't understand that so
I just had to point it out all right
let's put up a video Drew Brees doing it
I'm gonna record off your computer all
right Saints offense
you wrote body blows body blows I'll
just say this the game was 17 to 7 and
I'm going Ravens are up I already know
who's won this game and I'm watching the
film and I'm going there's no way the
Saints can win this game I mean there's
no way why the Ravens are controlling
the game on both sides of the ball both
sides Saints are just just squeaking by
to stay in the game but I wrote body
blows because the first drive of the
game right where have we talked about
what 15 play drive 10 minutes ok then
you go on to later in the game they put
a
long drive right before the half to get
seven points okay then it's the third
quarter they get I don't think it's a
third court I think I'm in the fourth
quarter now and hold on I'm just pulling
it up but then they get into the fourth
quarter here and oh it's a 12-play 77
yard drive 75 yard drive to make it 17
hitting the defense and Baltimore's
controlling everything but the body
blows like in a good boxing fight where
you always go you know I always hear the
announcer in the body and those fights
go you know these are gonna come back to
help this guy round 9 because he's gonna
wear this guy out and he's gonna put him
on the ground and it was all the third
down and fourth down conversions staying
consistent with the power run game long
drives it kept Baltimore's defense on
the field and listen being on the field
is one thing but being on the field
consecutively is a whole nother thing
like just like anything you could
probably squat 300 pounds once or twice
I don't know about that okay so let's
say your max is 250 okay let's just say
that 185 okay let's go with one anybody
you couldn't do it two or three times
give me a few minutes I'll do it again
but what if I ask you to keep doing it
25 times in a row probably wouldn't be
able you're gonna die out at some point
and when Drew Brees scrambled to the
right in the fourth quarter and was
getting sacked and threw the ball to
Michael Thomas to get the first down on
a third and eight amazing play it was an
amazing play and it just changed the
game
yes I ain't from that point on because
it was a it was like the first third
down that was like a little bit longer
and that the Ravens were like baby now
we got a game that's 17 7 they just go
that was the play that was what I will
in Ravens are [ __ ] you're going yeah
yeah and I was gonna man the Ravens are
gonna win this game there's no way
they're gonna convert this this is
they've been all over their stuff and
their and he made that play and it was
like the Ravens my gosh we're gonna stay
out here for 6 more plays and all of a
sudden you could see the momentum and
the New Orleans sidelines all the sudden
runs up the middle that were going for
zero there was push there for three and
then we were and then tell me if I'm
right yeah or if I'm wrong yeah not even
chimera not even Ingram it's when Taysom
comes in and he runs over a linebacker
and gets seven yeah that that's the guy
that I feel like they use the most when
they want that kill shot there's
something about seeing a white BYU
quarterback take the edge and knock out
a safety and get eight yards that just
kills your spirit yeah and he just pops
up smiling like a loo like a weirdo yeah
he's just like I love contact right left
go loves Taysom Hill yeah Sean Payton
does the the reason that I love him is I
don't believe that a lot of coaches
would ever give someone like Taysom Hill
a chance right I think a lot of coaches
would go he's not really a quarterback I
don't have a spot for him on my roster
and I feel like Sean Payton looks at
them and I mean we're watching a
game-winning drive on a third and three
where Sean Payton takes Drew Brees out
of the game yeah think about that I know
drew Brees comes out of the game on a
game-winning drive on third down and
Taysom Hill goes in Oh catch that stands
over there it isn't cuz that stands over
there at receivers just lay with ten
guys that's like they probably with 10
guys and Taysom Hill gets the first down
flips the ball like the true ghost all
right I'm done bye but like I don't
think a lot of coaches would ever have
that that idea vision the vision yeah it
would be too complicated
I got a quarterback adidas quarterback
stuff so I give a lot of credit to
Harbaugh
yeah they're making this Lamar Jackson
thing work right I I agree with you and
taste of milites pie and tight end now
and fullback
I'd rather I've tasted mother Lamar
Jackson right now I would do I would do
just for now yeah I mean I didn't like
how they used Lamar in this game first
of all Lamar has to lose weight
Lamar is not as fast he's getting into I
need to be a bigger quarterback mode he
is not as fast Lamar Jackson should be
able to turn the corner oncam Jordan and
he did not I mean he got like a few
yards after that but he stumbled and
fell his speed is not where it needs to
be and I always yeah I think it's a I'm
a firm believer that he should hand it
off every time because every time he
comes in I assume he's keeping it well
okay and then to that point okay I would
hand it off they had a third and eight
on like the 15 yard line going
and they put Lamar in Lamar and decided
to run his first pass of the season
right there are you kidding me
are you kidding me I don't even know
what to say that you're playing the same
playing the Saints you're four and two
and the Steelers are on a bye and yet
people are starting to you know play
good in the AFC you got the Chargers who
were five and two and the Patriots are
gonna be there and you got the Chiefs oh
yeah you're gonna let Lamar Jackson
throw his first meaningful NFL pass
inside the red zone against the Saints
and a set in a I think it was a it might
have been a I don't even know a Joe
Flacco played well nearly the entire
game the whole game Flacco played amaze
and his last trial was unbelievable it
was unbelievable but that to me makes
absolutely no sense at all we've we've
had a couple weeks in a row now where
you said Joe Flacco played amazing Joe
Flacco's other than the Bengals game is
really played I mean and you're not just
saying good you're using words like
amazing yeah yeah I'm cuz I'm using
things again like I don't even I'm not
even gonna know his stats and all those
kind of things I'm just telling you when
Joe says I want to hit that red bull's
eye that's 30 yards away yes it's the
the belt the bells ring and every time
it's the bells name is typically John
Brown right right right so yeah he's and
he's moving in the pocket a little you
know their offense is not glamorous but
a do what they do enough to where it you
know Joe if you give him protection he
can really throw it and he's doing that
and he certainly wasn't the reason they
lost this game I still feel good about
pumping up the Ravens preseason you said
that but that little o started for the
Ravens this week started at right tackle
did a really good job I told you I think
the Saints biggest issue is that pass
rush I still think the Ravens you want
to talk about team that needs to make a
move the Ravens need to if they need to
call LaShawn McCoy they need to call a
running back they are leaving yards on
the field you're not a big Alex Collins
Boreas Allen believer I mean big would
be an understatement I don't believe in
them at all they are third and fourth
running back material they are not first
or second and they are leaving yards on
the field on a weekly basis Kyle
looks like he runs so hard I I mean I'm
sure he is trying really hard and I
don't mean to be a jerk about him but
he's running hard and really not going
anywhere you know when I knew Alex
Collins was in trouble but when I beat
his ass and Dance Dance Revolution four
years ago yep damn right damn NFL Rookie
premiere we have video of Joey Bosa and
Hunter Henry playing Dance Dance
Revolution and then at the end Alex
Collins got up there and faced off with
Hendrick and federic beat him oh my god
at that moment I went this guy's and
he's like a Irish vendrick is the kid
that's hangs out at Dave & Buster's is
like you guys want to go he's got like
Dan DD I actually had DDR at my house so
I didn't have to go today thanks thanks
for bringing that out so you the Ravens
should trade for a running back I do I
do I think that they need somebody else
they need a difference-maker at the
episode not a difference-maker but they
need somebody that has another gear that
those guys don't and they need to they
know because those works are never gonna
break it to the outs no but and there's
so many plays that heard Alex Collins
best ability is turning a negative one
carry into a plus one carry but he's
never gonna turn a five into a 15 no
he's not but he does do that other thing
really well he does he's really good at
breaking up first - yeah you know it's
it's not against that Boreas doesn't
drop the ball no and Jeff aureus is just
big and slow I don't know what another
way to say it that's just the way it is
but man the page I mean the the Saints
that was amazing okay it really was what
they did to go up there like I said
bullying the Ravens at their own game
and out Baltimore about Baltimore
Baltimore in Baltimore okay that doesn't
happen very much and yeah six or
fourteen on third down like people are
gonna look at that and go oh six or 14
oh that's pretty good but it's really
more than that like it's other things
okay it's not six for 14 it ends up
being 10 for 14 because the the the em
effort head coach went for it on fourth
down and kept those drives alive he does
things that I love were on like third
and seven he does like a draw play and
turns it into fourth and three because
he already knows he's going for it on
fourth down
yes and I've always believed this too
when I'll sleep on third and eight
acting up at his own end zone and they
got the first down when a team believes
that they've stopped you on third down
and you're gonna punt and they release a
motion right I always think it's great
to go for it on fourth down because
they've already celebrate all ready like
yeah we won this series and you're like
oh [ __ ] I got no right was there any
other games that you saw that you really
want to focus on because I will say we
got some film requests from YouTube yeah
and one of them was right Saints third
down conversions in the second half
Tyler Mooney see ok and you just talked
about right that the third downs for the
Saints were fantastic fantastic I mean
whether it was Brees like I said there
was a third and eighth he ran a toss
sweep to Kamara one time you know yeah
there was a number a little third and
three third and fourth rows that they
made that's where if they get you in a
certain situation thinking you third and
five or less they're gonna get the first
down more times than not or they're
gonna get real close to where like you
said they can go for it on fourth and
one do you want to go through these mr.
YouTube YouTube comment I was just gonna
say go for it uh Raphael villa villa
Mazar Adam feeling in the Vikings
offense yeah it's not stopping anytime
soon right you texted me during the game
yeah said you're still worried about the
Vikings offense it still looks a little
bit too simple all they have are
crossers to Thielen there yeah their
offense is not as good as last year
think about what you're seeing from
their offense and let's put it all in
the context everybody's listening out
there this is not gonna go well well the
truth well no the this stats look great
I'm actually gonna praise Adam Thielen
here so this is go for no I want to hear
the truth
I'm just laughing in my head because I
know how people were gone I don't think
the offense is as good as last year as a
whole last year they were kind of a
machine they were one of the best
running teams in football they were
amazing a play-action pass what I'm
gonna tell you here is they are not the
same well-oiled machine but they have a
quarterback who's pretty damn awesome
and he's thrown two - pretty damn
awesome receivers feel and I think it's
more awesomer than Diggs okay but yes
and then think about the game first
Drive long third down bomb touchdown
Jets they had the ball inside the Jets
territory like four times and came away
with like two field goals they didn't do
anything then it was latavius Murray
breaks a big
run then it was its fourth and eighth
bomb from Kirk Cousins yeah think about
an Eagles game backed up bomb to atom
feeling there really a think about the
Packers game
touchdown down the sidelines huge bomb
over the top to Thielen it's a big play
offense right now it's not an offense
that just dissect you and Surgical like
it was last year I like some of the
other great offenses and I'm not saying
that can't keep up I'm just saying
that's a hard thing to keep up and we
got to keep our eye on it because when
you're always relying on that aspect
that will be harder to do against the
salty quality football team we saw it
with the Tampa Bay Bucs a Ryan
Fitzpatrick write that but what were you
gonna pray stealing for Oh
I mean Thielen is just he's a hell of a
player and I'm just saying that yet
their offense of overall is not as good
but with this quarterback and feeling
and digs ability to beat one-on-one
coverage bacon on a lot of weeks just
say well fine we could do it ourselves
us three let's do it
how are you seeing any double coverage
of Adam Thielen oh no again that's why
he's not a top-5 receiver because the
Jets put Darryl Roberts on them for most
of the game and do you know Darryl
Roberts's do you know what number he
wears don't know 27 you're wrong so yeah
that's what I mean so again those are
the arguments I make when you go Adam
Thielen should be it yeah but why can't
I say that defensive coordinator is dumb
you could say that he's done I think
that's a justifiable comment yeah he's
definitely taking a risk but I would
also claim to you on those plays it's
not like he's blowing by these people
it's not like we're going it going like
whoa he's out of here that was crazy to
ask that guy to cover him man and then
it's like oh I just missed the ball when
he caught that touch they're out running
my chat with my fantasy league yeah
there was a legitimate discussion is
Adam feeling the best wide receiver in
football with like five people giving it
the thumbs up emoji oh my gosh guys are
you kidding me
gosh that's what is this like what come
on you're that you're that much in
disagreement to say is that no yes sorry
no negative ghostrider patterns full I
don't even know what to say there's so
many things I really want to say wide
receivers ever done what he's done okay
except for Charlie Hannigan in 1964 the
Houston Oilers
it's awesome and he's really awesome but
he's not demanding the attention of some
of the guys that are in front of him
there is a meme online and Roderick
Sherrod has brought it to YouTube contra
Biscay throw left contra Biscay throw
left people think he is Zoolander
disease and he can throw right now that
you're saying that I think about it he
does throw the ball to the right a whole
lot now he's thrown some Easter on some
to the left like the Tampa Bay me
definitely had a few toes left but
you're right now that I'm thinking of
most of his big throws that jump to my
mind are to the right side
have you ever heard of anything like
this no not really
all right just in your next film I'll
try to keep a closer look
Cowboys Cowboys Redskins Cowboys are
offensively deficient I watched the film
they lost a battle on both sides of the
ball up front and really their offense
lost them the game that's all I can
really say their offense it was a field
position game that's what it was
and Dallas really could never change the
field position for like the first three
quarters of the football game and that
was the big reason the Redskins ole line
is pretty damn good and I'm going to
double down on my they need to be a
power run football team are you worried
about Zeke long term I mean I'm this
season like no but I still don't think
Zeke looks the same way he did our
rookie year and I don't think his legs
look the same either I'm just gonna say
that so I think some of these superstar
guys like I'll throw Marshawn Lattimore
in this too because I know you didn't
read all my notes
I mean Marshall Lattimore couldn't catch
John Brown Marcus Williams caught him
like that's an issue to me you're a top
ten pick you're a corner that guy was
holding a ball in his hand you weren't
you should catch him not the free safety
you guys started at the equal spot I
would actually argue you got a little
head start on Marcus Williams
you had a dive and completely whiffed
Marcus Williams ran and caught him those
are little things I look at to go either
one you're not training as hard as you
should be because you're not under the
college-like scope all the time or
you're gonna be here at 6 a.m. for
workouts or that you're being treated
like a professional like a man and you
didn't have combine workouts in April
and March to get you still in shape
right so those are things I worry about
like with young guys don't fall into
that trap now you got some money in your
pocket you're maybe staying out a little
late things like you're going to parties
and being introduced as all pro exactly
I will say that's why I'm so impressed
with Kareem on exactly that's why you
you should be there's no one that I
underestimated more this year than creme
on mainly because we saw that Super Bowl
I went this guy but got yeah I know and
I'm sitting there like I'll tell you man
NFL players are sometimes underwhelming
yes like and I saw creme hunt wearing
like kind of a baggy polo and I was like
this guy had that Pepsi Jackie look he
look like nothing now I'll say look like
I'll say in his defense guys he runs
like some four he runs like something he
doesn't give a damn what he looks like
for you that's what I'm gonna tell you
too and I would bet you a guy like that
I should actually like guys that shot
worrying worse clothes no I think he's
basically going I'm really secure in Who
I am as an athlete as a player I was
really the season's over and he probably
hadn't worked out at one day so he done
like six weeks of like chillin chillin
right
who knows what chillin would consist of
yeah but he wasn't in the waiting room
grindin like a guy like him could come
back a month later after the Super Bowl
we were like Harry we need to start
working out four days and you'd be like
whoa he is rocked up like that's what
kind of gifted person that that guy is
to seize their body switch again switch
like that right I scrolled back and I
found the quotes from Monday
David Gillan he wrote this down for us
we're Baltimore screw Baltimore they out
Baltimore Baltimore in Baltimore Wow Ben
Ferraro throw in the white towel is
something you've been saying I have
which is not how you're supposed to say
that and then why it's throw in the
white towel or raise the white flag
throw in the towel or raise the white
flag oh you're right it is I guess you
would say that well in my world and
rocky for Sylvester Stallone throws in a
white towel everybody try this out most
towels are white for the most part but I
know not all this is a diverse world we
got oh I was just saying I don't like
white towels because I want to see the
dirt on them yeah well for a great towel
well how do you shower and clean
yourself dirty let me
Chuck over 74 tweeted at us how could
you forget rocket wobbler I laughed so
hard at that bortles is out here
throwing these damn rocket wild rocket
la fleurs yes yeah good luck try to
catch a rocket while the opposite of a
piss missile yeah there's a rocket
wobble yeah a rocket wobbler like I
don't know where that thing's going he
threw it so hard it's wobbling and I'm
probably gonna dislocate a finger but
I'll catch it if it's here throwing
rocket wobblers on Sunday you should
throw in the white towel it's still
better than Jason Witten you see that he
pulled a cat out of his head what a
rabbit a repo rabbit out of his that's
where you got the rabbit Jason what's
really funny is he wanted to say a
rabbit out of his ass and then he was
like rabbit ahead and rabbit out of your
head man I feel bad all right Noah Gatto
won I think y'all should really consider
doing a weekly segment where Simms talks
about his favorite play from Sunday have
him go deep into the zine and why it
worked and how it was set up thanks love
the podcast III don't disagree with that
was there any plays that kind of stick
out from the film you were just watching
or any of the design let me just we can
make this a thing moving forward to just
think of that real quick don't give us a
half-ass breakdown this man no I'm just
trying to think I'm well I'm just real
quickly looking through the teams just
going is there anyone that really jumped
yeah I have a simple one yeah and it
really wasn't that intense and obviously
this is not for me but this is part of
little there was the dropped tyree kill
50-yard touchdown oh right and the only
reason that I'm bringing it up is it's
crazy to me that Tyree kill can start on
the left come in and then run out and he
outrun triple coverage yeah like he had
a safety on top a corner on the outside
a corner on the inside and he just ran
to the middle field and ran out and he
was wide open and that went to your
Tyree kills the best wide receiver the
NFL because I don't think any other wide
receiver could have gotten open there
but that was the one play that I was
like wow like I wish that when I'm
watching NFL games that after a big play
or like I believe that every broadcast
like on the Odell should have kept
running they should give us the coaches
film the very next thing I don't need to
see the supers
zooom I don't need to see the fist-pump
on the sidelines I think we're at a
point with the NFL where if there's a
big play immediately after get on the
coach's film give me the yellow pen and
let's figure it out and I don't I know
that a lot of times they go to
commercial break because they want to
see it for themselves and how many times
have you seen Chris Collinsworth circle
a guy and go watch Fletcher Cox in these
circles Timmy Jernigan he goes hi Circle
the wrong guy I don't care but give me
the on top like we should as football
fans not have to pay for NFL game pass
and study film to see what's going on
yeah it really should be your job so
that's I saw the game for the coaches
film right afterwards and it made sense
right that was my rant on I thought I
read kill is just a weapon so I don't
even want any plays while I was doing my
little thing I thought about the
touchdown pass to the Rams that he threw
to Brandon cooks in the left front of
the endzone Gulf just play-action fake
they always hit they always hit cook on
these crossers crossers he sells the
crosser hard corners going oh he turned
on the crosser I'm gonna go and he stops
and he comes back out that was a great
play I found lately I've been getting
more of a kick out of like the gadget
place for the most part like Kansas City
I haven't got to that film yet they
always have some fun down the field
shots like to what you were talking
about but I'm getting more of a kick
lately out of like I like talking about
tying plays together like we talked
about with the Patriots on the first
play run up the middle 18 yards looks
like the same run fake it screen to the
running back you didn't see that coming
10 yards
those are the things I look at a lot of
times to go wow but I will start to mark
those more yeah yeah as we go forward I
Matthew Stafford and a few throws on
that game that were jaw-dropping it
wasn't necessarily play design but I
went uh-oh here comes Matthew Stafford
I'm sewing on the Lions right now it's
pretty crazy I was just thinking though
I saw a clip I think the check down
posted of like big guy touchdowns dude
Andy's always been doing this Don Terry
Poe the jump touchdown pass he just
I appreciate coaches at work it's really
like yeah
Oh Thursday night football Miami Houston
not talking spreads anything like that
Brock Tober comes back Brock Osweiler
all the wide receivers heard on Miami
Houston deshaun Watson gets back on his
bus drives back
Houston started off Owen three there now
four and three yeah
Miami started off three and oh they're
now four and three so they their same
record but different journeys to get
here
I feel like Houston's operating at a
much higher level than Miami is right
now III mean I feel like they're
certainly on a different trajectory
right now and I feel like they have the
best unit I really their defense is the
best unit of the four I would agree with
that
there's no doubt about that especially
but the way clowny and merciless played
last week merciless is back to ya
merciless was real last week was the
first game I was like oh there's 50 now
he's this writer playing well too he is
so when you have the reader merciless
watt clowny honey badger you know he
looks good bra Jonathan Joseph's still
solid who's that linebacker removed or
antara Broderick McKinney solid I know
they got a lot of their they're always
one of my favorite watches because they
want to kick your ass
I would expect them to win a tough
physical football game somewhere in the
I'm gonna say 24 to 17 right where are
you with deshaun Watson right now
deshaun Watson I think last week yeah
again watch that Jaguars D was really
good he managed the game and played the
game correctly and that's what you
should have done did he look hurt when
he was playing not really I can't say
they did he threw some phenomenal
footballs to DeAndre Hopkins he touched
Hopkins is an interesting matchup for
Ramsey because Ramsey's not scared of
his speed but Hopkins ain't scared of
his physicality either yeah but you know
what two years ago
Ramsey owned him I know we talked about
it for an entire offseason yes I know I
watched that game it was like Hopkins
studied the boxing film and had a
counter for he won a lot of his battles
he was not gonna be punked at the line
of scrimmage of that game and he gave it
back - Jalen Ramsey
real good he did he definitely did do
you think Kenyan Drake and the running
game can get going Frank Gore against
Texans or is that just no we
sit back and you smoke I do think that
you'll see a few plays gashed the Texans
because the Texas will do some things
upfront every now and then and we're Oh
Debbi on clowny he was a DN and all of a
sudden he comes shooting through the
beak out standing up and you get stuck
with a run play that's called it so I do
think there would be a few opportunities
where he'll get out on the edge but I
think overall I just look at Texans as
being a little more talented yeah
and the better coach football thing we
have an interview with Mean Joe green
coming up right when we wrap up here I
got one more for you
the 500 Touchdown Club yeah Brett Favre
Drew Brees Tom Brady Peyton Manning yeah
Brett Favre Drew Brees Tom Brady Peyton
Manning pretty good generate are they
all in the same generation first or is
Manning
I feel like Manning and Brady are in one
I feel like Favre is the one before and
I feel like Brees is the one after yeah
I know like Brees is kind of like in the
Brady Manning era just maybe a year or
two later he was drafted with Vick in l1
it's around so he is the same thing same
era but then maybe Manning and Farwell
Manning was in 98 yep Favre was early
90s so far is not another yeah far far
was 92 or never even before that 91 so
Manning Brees Brady and far maybe even
four that you have one drive to win a
game who you pick it for one drive on
same same coaching staff same weapon not
taking I just know that right now so all
automatically out taking breath all
because of the interception against
those Saints and the Giants and the
giant and I've witnessed them throw is
definitely protecting the ball the least
without a doubt okay so he's yeah he
also might make the most unreal throw
and win the game with that but I'm
leaving a minute and a half left on the
clock for the other ride I would rather
have the more consistent one here Brees
Brady or manna to me it comes down to I
have my Brady and Manning for me it's
one of those two mmm but I've never
thought about this but one drive I think
I won't go is Tom Brady that's why yeah
I got to go with Tom
paetynn is amazing definitely but Brady
has just done it way too many times so
many different ways knows the
situation's how to play them and of
course some of them you've also seen it
so many times
exactly right all right no other
questions yeah far breeze Brady Manning
playing from behind who would you rather
have ooh I'd rather have Peyton
I feel like Peyton with momentum and
it's like it's about clock management
stops smart decisions use of timeouts
I just think Peyton is the orchestrator
and maybe it's also because I've seen
that a lot think of the Tampa Bay game
and all that like Peyton Manning coming
back I just feel like that I feel like
Peyton Manning is better coming back
then then playing with a lead I mean it
did seem that way I mean it's when they
were that their most dangerous I it's
between now they're Brees is pretty damn
gosh they're all good gosh I mean the
other Brady only brought him back from
28 to three in Super Bowl 51 Oh
it's it's Manning or Barve I think for
me when you're from behind behind yes
because I just feel like they're gonna
make some throws like Farbs gonna push
the envelope again he might throw an
interception where you go okay we lost
yeah but there's a good chance that he's
gonna make three or four throws that you
go damn we're packing this thing hmm but
I think I would go with Manning as well
Manning changed the game he is a game
changer that's where I hope everybody
realizes out there that yeah his legacy
won't be Tom Brady um but I think in his
prime he is definitely in the
conversation for the greatest
quarterback of all time Manning and he
is a first of all one of the most
amazing stats I think we talked about
this on Monday is the fact that he went
to four Super Bowls with four different
head coaches you said that is an amazing
stat I mean that's an amazing that's
like it's like the 32 teams thing but
he's a game changer like LT and some
other generational players because he
was truly the first offensive
coordinator quarterback of this era like
right it used to be a thing with Johnny
Unitas where he just draw it up in the
huddle and we do that and then I went to
totally into the coach's hands for third
years and then all sudden the sheriff
came to town Payton and Payton was like
I gotta get me some papa john's and he
started running the show far breeze
pretty manning one drive to win a game
or rogers o
rogers and that this is a left go
podcast rogers is like the most for sure
thing ever
awesome i have two things before we go
okay one we're going to Mean Joe green I
know I just got offered a phone
interview with John Ramsey so we're
gonna do that coming up soon nice get
that scheduled right number one or if
he's actually gonna talk to us yeah he
hasn't really been talking lately
Mike Guerra follo on Twitter just put
this out Malcolm Jenkins speaking about
the players coalition and noting his
constant support of Colin Kaepernick
when he added quote I can turn on the
tape this week of our opponent the
Jaguars
and see that Colin Kaepernick deserves a
job Malcolm Jenkins just said I love
that Malcolm Jenkins said that I love
that and I just have so bad Eric Reid
for going at Malcolm Jenkins I don't
like that one other thing juju Smith
Shuster bought 100 more than a hundred
Mega Millions tickets and afterwards he
said I tried to win so that we can get
levy on back but it didn't work
alright guys here is our interview with
legendary Hall of Famer one of the
absolute pinnacles of defense in history
the NFL Mean Joe Greene what's up Joe
Greene Joe Greene yeah welcome to The
Sims and left go podcast my good friend
yep how does that sound
[Music]
you know the 20th century was Phil Simms
but now we're in the new century okay so
it's Chris Sims now all right did you
did you get did you get to hit my dad at
all back in the day I think I did good I
think I did I'm glad I hope you actually
I may have been the first you know I
think you are one of them is my father
still talks about his first on the field
experience and you guys were still in
the game in a preseason football game
yep she was preseason football game I
think I said something to him that he
didn't forget right but you said like
what welcome to the NFL or something
like that after playing you guys who
can't get worse all right we got Mean
Joe green
compliments of the hometown Hall of
Famers presented by Ford Motor Company
you were being honored at your alma
mater University of North Texas on
October 26 they're unveiling a plaque
for Mean Joe making North Texas the 120
second official school of the Pro
Football Hall of Fame Mean Joe that's
kind of feel pretty good yes it does yes
it does i'm excited about that I'm
honored that Hall of Fame thought about
me for doing this and and the Ford Motor
Company for sponsoring is how I think
the first place I'd like to start is how
did you end up Mean Joe green at North
Texas where was Texas A&M where was
Oklahoma where was University of Texas
how did that even happen well all three
of those schools were not in the lot in
in the area where I was being recruited
they were probably someplace in Mars
they hadn't heard about guys like me
that's great they obviously were on Mars
if they miss evaluated you well that was
doing that that was doing I think my
senior year was 65 and that you know
that Chris that was the first year that
the Southwest Conference was integrated
Journal of vias with the SMU write that
year in North Texas had been integrated
for about 10 years at that time so
and I when I chose my Lexus I was happy
about it and I haven't regretted a
moment yeah you shouldn't I think it I
think it all worked out in the the right
way
okay so Mean Joe green 70 Steelers I
want to know what your outlook on the
NFL is right now do you think the NFL
the modern-day NFL is getting soft with
some of their rules and the quarterback
things I would just love to hear your
perspective on this well Chris and I've
never never been a fan of quarterbacks
it was very tough to like my quarterback
of course I'm just kidding about him the
kind of it's okay I don't you know it's
hard for a player to be on the field and
he is bored of contact right you can't
hit him that's that's not football
no because they you know they they have
taken away above the shoulders and
they've taken away below actually saying
it below the knees but it appears maybe
below the waist
yeah I think you're right and so what
does that leave ya much not much right
and Chris to tell you the truth you know
better than me if they leave if it
becomes illegal for those guys to go
empty that probably would would would
would would improve the health of these
quarterbacks able to keep our back in
the backfield there may be a tidy and
lock right that would help but it goes
against the idea of creating more
offense right but it's I think it helps
safety but what I really think is that
we were in transition yes
in transition and we don't really like
the place where we are off on the
standpoint of the health of the game so
we try to make it healthy healthier
right and as we and that that has to do
with changing the rules so while we're
changing that we're trying to get to a
better place
place we're just in transition and
that's a that's the rough spot yeah
it bothers me Joe it really does even as
an ex wimpy quarterback I still think
it's getting a little too offensive one
sided and the defense can't use their
physicality anymore and some would say
that it's getting a little one-sided
when it comes to contracts to mean Joe I
wish you could have been around hunter I
wish you could have been around when
there was you know free agency and the
salaries were so crazy your former team
the Steelers Le'Veon Bell holding out
does it make sense to you when you see a
guy holding out for his worth even
though I know back when you guys were
playing I don't even think that was an
option well I think that you know I have
a hard time of discussing someone else's
position in terms of his financial
position sure my thought and when I was
playing all I was in all I was
interested in was when I was my contract
was I wasn't worried about anybody
else's unless we needed those guys to
play and they were holding down today I
find it very very hard for a guy not to
be able to even in today's world because
of to survive on 14 million dollars a
year now if that's not true what I've
read in the paper about what was offered
Le'Veon Bell well I saw where they they
said they offered him 74 five and he
refused him that when I go back and
think about that
see man what's wrong with you you know
yeah I know
here he now I'm from the school of
thought that he wasn't available for the
Steelers because of injury okay that's
that's no fault of his he's playing the
game you know you've heard but he was
also not available for substance abuse
and now that's a whole new picture yeah
because I think that that takes away his
ability to negotiate to be the the
highest-paid player because that plays
into the equation it has to because now
you're talking about the character of
the guy that you've given all this money
to now that's a that's a solid position
for management yeah I agree
it's certainly something they gotta take
into account I mean yeah the other thing
is I'd like to talk I mean about your
dynasty a lot the 70s dynasty the
Steelers and it was one of the best ever
you guys the 49ers but I would love to
hear your view of this new modern-day
dynasty the New England Patriots and
what kind of jumps out to you that makes
them so special like you guys back in
the day just to me immediately
yeah is the goddess in the catbird seat
the coach right
that's what jumps out and I haven't been
any in any of his coach Belichick
meetings but they have to be similar to
coaching those meetings because he has
not reminds for my knowledge and it
hasn't gotten public he doesn't tolerate
the nonsense now I would say that I mean
he's had I can't think of this guy's
name the running back from Cincinnati
that came to yeah Corey Dillon Corey
Dillon right was proud of that he
he had the reputation being
troublemakers right
[Music]
jonbi mom we ever any my house right
suppose a little trouble I like Mandy me
too I didn't do I played with a very
Yuri diamond he's a football savant yeah
but he had no problem and for for Bill
Belichick
Bill Belichick and there was another guy
that played for Pittsburgh couldn't play
for Pittsburgh blonde oh yes exactly and
he had two good years there had a New
England yeah so he's he's had some of
the guys that had problems elsewhere but
didn't have the problems that New
England right and and I just think that
that's why they're successful that's
where well you know they got a
quarterback that's that's very accurate
right very accurate and they come up
with some good football scheme so
knowledgeable ways to attack defenses I
mean it's always been a crossing route
and right down the middle right the
easiest what was the easiest path for
you to throw Chris right down the sea
that's that's right I mean especially if
the guy is six seven to seventy and can
run like Gronkowski they got to think
about where to go here yeah exactly
another three seconds or so to decide if
he's gonna catch that ball or not
alright so but I just think that they
they are ahead of their ahead of the
game right now or he might yeah
and that's that's why they have been I
don't know how many Super Bowls in the
last eight ten years
yeah there there it's a lot it's a
during the AFC Championship game every
year that's a we could count on for sure
hundred percent exactly so that you
don't look up on that that's right you
have to be doing something well and at
one time you know the Steelers had it
right and now I have to truthfully say
that it's New England yep there's a lot
of Hall of Famers on that New England
team balichek will be Brady Gronk all
those guys again Mean Joe green with us
because of the whole town Hall of Famers
presented by the Ford Motor Company
October 26 gonna be at North Texas there
are two alumnus from that school that
speak to my heart one Mean Joe green I
mean it was it's one of the greatest
nicknames I've ever heard my dad would
always tell me about the robbery the
other one was Stone Cold Steve Austin
and I'm just curious if what is your
experience with stone cold or do you are
you a fan of stone cold cuz I always
wanted to slam two beers together and
Russell because of stone cold when I was
growing up I never met him I've only
seen him on TV yeah I never met him we
need to make sure he's there for this
event on October 26 yeah that'd be good
that'd be good that that's a big plank
probably probably he could pick it up
Chris always Chris always makes fun of
wrestling fans because he thinks
wrestling is fake I'm just curious what
means you well yeah that's why I mean
that's why he hasn't met him yet he's
not watching wrestling I do not want to
get into the ring with anyone that can
bind me well that's not fair now you're
a little up there an age so that's not
fair
back in the day nobody would want a
bottom good body-slamming you think your
body's livid just three weeks ago at
turn 72 is that way to go man let it go
you're winning that's all we could say
all right last thing before we let you
go cuz it's been a great honor talking
to you it really has who is your
favorite defensive lineman and football
to watch right now
oh boy you know is it sue is it Aaron
Donald is it Fletcher [ __ ] JJ was it
Khalil Mac I know I'm putting you on the
spot here but I figured I have to ask
one all time great about who jumps out
to jumps out to you well I'll say this
flincher Cox as a big guy he's a big
interior lineman right
he shows power and he shows quickness
and I don't see he plays with the
temperament that that I think you have
to have I know you have to have he's not
taking any any gunk from anybody all
right
wait a second so Fletcher Cox does not
have a nickname and I am an Eagles fan
and there is something about that word
mean that means a lot do you think
Fletcher Cox plays to the level of
earning a nickname like mean Fletcher
Cox name is going to be very hard to
play with yes yeah you know I I was on
the I went to the sideline just before
the game last year yeah and I had a
chance to check shake his hand and wish
him good luck just before the kickoff
yeah yeah and the other guy that I like
is uh he's a smaller guy but he's an
interior guy I'm talking about into you
guys now yeah yeah Donald Donald
unbelievable some fantastic things
inside with his with his explosiveness
and his quickness sudden change of
direction yeah and you know he he can
rush the passer from the inside and
still not give up the gaping holes to
get it done right usually when you
rushing the passer all the time you're
gonna give ups and some running Lang's
yep he doesn't do that nice which is
really special
yep really special in there
the outside guys is that guy from Denver
Miller
oh yeah he can give he can get off with
the ball and he can turn the corner and
get a lean I'm about four inches yes it
is it's amazing how he can mean Joe you
are the man a Hall of Famer as a person
as a player and again October 26 North
Texas getting the big time plaque
already as a statue compliments of the
Ford Motor Company Mean Joe thank you so
much for your time dude really
appreciate it thank you be good man
Mean Joe memory Joe green okay I mean
Joe just turned 72 right I'm almost
positive no okay my grandmom's 82 but 72
and still able to go I like Fletcher Cox
Aaron Donald's got good hand placement
good jump off Von Miller can has a solid
lean right the Patriots are good because
they do a lot of slants and down the
seam passes why is Mean Joe at 72 more
accurately watching the NFL the most
analysts that I see on TV yeah I mean he
talks a little bit slower well okay yeah
but he's 72 no doubt and he's paying
attention and he's got the eye for it
it's a trained eye he's seen it no mean
Fletcher casa I love how he was like I
don't think it sells don't think it
sells right I also hey in this day and
age where all we talk about is the
negative was football and it's so
physical and we got to protect the
brains there's a guy at 72 years old his
nickname was Mean Joe green he didn't
get that because he was like you know
playing two-hand touch on the inside
yeah and there he is functioning at a
very high level and still really aware
of what's going on in all aspects all
hey Nick cue up that outro music we're
gonna in the podcast right here but
really with with Mean Joe I look at it
and comparing Belichick to Chuck Noll
yeah
makes complete sense sure uh Chuck was
no-nonsense and I think you ever hear
about
all right so mean Joe's getting up the
plaque at North Texas right and I want
that plaque at Texas for Chris Simms I
don't think it's coming their Hall of
Fame broadcaster I made like I'm on
something there but no plaques if we do
this podcast for 40 more years together
depends how many bad things I say attend
South Texas between out of that hundred
dollar head yes I for Simms he's not
homies vendrick would say the lef koe
holla holla holla holla holla holla
holla we will be doing all of the games
on the Friday morning podcast breaking
them down against the spread Simms
continues to make up ground let's see if
you can keep it going you hear me Joe
Lepke all right Pete Joe laughs guess